why is the mile in such a dominant
position it doesn't make any sense right
like you're just sitting on top of the
stomach of a person it makes all sense
if you think what's forget forget
fighting forget Jiu Jitsu like you've
never trained what's the one position
the most dominant position you can get
over another human being one the most
for you which one it is like the most
dominant position that you can get over
not the human being
so if we were just because the way I
think about it is putting myself in like
a six seven eight year old self without
knowing any martial arts and I had an
older brother who would beat the [ __ ]
out of me
uh yeah it probably was Mount
it what
but
well yes okay so we both didn't know but
if we knew something it'd probably be
back control
if in the back control you're under the
other person the thing being under is
the most dominant position it can be
over another person
you mean like a back control if I'm on
your back oh like that you can move you
can roll I cannot stop you rolling yeah
maybe you can even stand up how dominant
is that yeah but if we're the same size
both untrained it doesn't matter have
you seen kids do they do that okay
mount looks and feels like dominance
when you're two eight-year-olds fighting
okay I don't know I don't know why it
feels that way it could be some
animalistic thing maybe it is actual
dominance I don't know but it feels like
if you're on trained you can just buck
your way out of it it feels unstable it
feels unstable to hold them out unless
you know what you're doing right no well
if you if you're multiple both of your
hands on the floor yeah just your hands
to think it's easier to take somebody
off
yeah maybe not to think it's easy to
remove the hand and bring them out the
hands on the floor I'm straight I'm
leaning in
yeah you're right it's hot
I mean you don't need to know fighting
to hold yourself down yeah but you're
right when you take the arms off and
balancing then it gets tricky because
when you're trying to uh I think what
happens I'm thinking back to eight year
old
because my my brother's five years older
than me and he would do the usual like
stop hitting yourself thing and you I
think he'll be in mouth like hitting me
with my own hands uh from at a place of
Love Of course
um I love them deeply and it was very
formative and uh positive experience for
me okay
um I think yeah the weakness is when he
takes
well when the person who has your mouth
takes their arms off to to do something
but even if you keep your hands opened
yeah when I'm falling
yeah you can I'm not falling so I'm
speaking about untrained people I feel
like they get greedy they try to do
stuff the other day I watched my
nine-year-old daughter yeah we're in a
friend's house
there's a whole bunch of kids that
they're playing
and when I looked
she's mounting a boy her age her size he
cannot Escape
wow she probably has seen no she
translated she's been training for
almost a year and a half okay which is
not much I mean she's a nine-year-old
daughter she's a girl over a boy has she
seen footage of you maybe she picked up
no but she appreciate she'd been
training for a year and a half so she
has an idea what Mount is but
I mean it talks about skills I don't
never taught her them out yeah she has
you know she had lessons at the Academy
like any other kid did she make him cry
or no but he couldn't escape
which which other position would she be
able to hold that boy
you know in the back he would roll it
out that's true like he couldn't come
out from underneath her shoes in decades
like there is no other most dominant
position that you can pin the other
person couldn't you argue from that
perspective side control no no because I
control you have to to hold the other
person
and it's you're not free you you cannot
release them but inside control your
hips are not on top of theirs
so
they can't Buck you off right
can you if you're holding them a little
bit and then you can hit them with one
hand but his head is here you're gonna
hurt him here by the time you're doing
that but then he has his arms free and
if you turn towards your legs
then he's away from your arms you're not
even has the perfect angle I mean it is
a good position you can hit you can
dominate but it's not the best position
to be over the other person he can knee
you in the head at the same time you
punch him then there's a knee come into
your head
I love playing Devil's Advocate with
Hydra Grace about two eight-year-olds
fighting and you and you your head is
closer to his hand yeah maybe he can
give throw you a punch all right so
would you choose to be inside control of
a mouth
getting in the head well for a person
who in competition prefers neon belly
over a mouth
um but that's my weakness that's my
failure as a human being holding him out
is is can be tricky it's very hard
of course it's hard
but what is easy he's controlling neon
Bell is easier but your belly is easy
easier I'm not saying black belt level
I'm saying well maybe even black belt
these are for what to hold somebody
to make them squirm and hurt
to create openings with a big guy yeah
you can you can't yeah
he's gonna push it back and come up in
the mouth he can't sit up not when he
mounted him the thing is also about Mao
is people on the bottom of mouth Panic
more
it's the most exposure you you have
because the first arms are free you
cannot touch him his head is too high
there's nothing he can do his legs won't
get you anyway he might touch your lower
back it's like nothing
you do you you most expose being in the
mouth
I rather you hoping side control a
thousand times the amount of me and
having to look up for your fist come
down
yeah side control I heard you you cannot
hurt me
okay hold me but I'm hugging you if I
hug you tight what can you do against me
hold it it seems maybe it's just from uh
and again I'm arguing just for the fun
of it but
um
it seems like a more difficult
skill to learn
to apply a huge amount of pressure and
weight from Mount you don't have some
slight pressure and weight from mouth or
not apply pressure but be heavy right
you don't necessarily need to be heavy
you don't
no why do you as people say you feel
extremely heavy if I'm putting if I'm
being heavy I cannot attack
it's I I have to choose I can be heavy
just to penalize you know just to
pin them take the energy out you know to
make them suffer but the moment that I
decide to attack I can only behave him
if I'm sitting up straight that's when
my all my weight can drops down if I'm
high then I'm sitting on your chest and
on your own solar plexus that's the
worst position to be said added on the
person because that's where he breathed
so you're in a high mouth sitting up
straight that's when you can I can be
very heavy I can make people you know
feel my weight and you know be very
uncomfortable but I'm not in a position
to attack the moment that I want to
attack my body has to lean forward I
have to approach the you know the neck
of the arms the amount that I do that my
weight comes off my hips it goes to my
knees the way it is off you
but at that point if you have now I'm
attacking I'm no longer heavy on you but
you want to be at that point to remove
any of the defenses they have or some of
the defenses by getting there now now
I'm like either getting trying to get
your call or bringing your elbow across
to talk to your unlock so what are some
interesting details along the way that
are tough to get to figure out
what were the big leaps for you from
white belt to to the best in the world
it's you're trying to attack the neck
you know putting one hand in the collar
you're priving yourself that hand to
place it on the floor yeah so now you're
vulnerable to get bridge to get rolled
over because if your hands are free
trying to roll you over you stopped the
moment they put your hand in the
person's collar now you have to be very
careful with your body positioning very
careful the distribution of the weight
yeah and how you you know how high you
sit you know how tall you you your upper
body goes
and then the biggest challenge comes as
you try the second hand that's the you
know for the for the choke that's the
biggest challenge the second hand
because you already have you you know
you already don't have one hand now you
you are trying the second hand and
if one of my hand is in you you know as
a uh defending yourself have two hands
one hand is already on one side this
this side is getting attacked you have
two hands blocking that I have one hand
there's no help for that hand I cannot
remove anything that's the biggest
challenge getting one hand getting past
two
and not getting rolled over but I also
have to have two hands on bottom I have
two hands and can also turn and do all
kinds of stuff yeah
and my whole mind and everything is
focused on that second hand
it's a big challenge it's hard very hard
is there an art to getting the first
hand into a place where you it's less of
an art because it's easier I'll say most
times I get my first hand in is when you
you try and some move you're trying to
escape you're pushing I get with the
first handing as an opportunity and it's
gonna sit there for a while
and now and I go as deep as I can so the
first hand because the second hand is
the hardest I have to compensate the
first thing to be as deep as I can but
if I cannot get the first hand in deep I
won't try the second
I need that first hand deep then I go
for this and it's deep in it everything
is like super like tight super tight the
first hand has to be super tight
otherwise the chance of failing is very
big okay does the opponent usually feel
like they're screwed at that point also
no as you put in the first hand in the
moment that I position myself just prior
to attempt the second hand I think the
way I my body is positioned the way I'm
I'm collapsing with my weight and the
field is like it's I'm in a
this is terrible yeah how long did it
take you to figure out how to reposition
your weight once the first hand is in
very quickly because door get breached
out
okay so that there's a good feedback
loop yeah because one must take you out
like one off positioning you out but you
still have to do that against the best
people in the world yeah where is the
way out for most people like if you were
in Mount against brusheshire or some of
the best defenses in the world
the way out is to I mean obviously is to
defend themselves and you know prevent
the first hand to get deep and I'll say
the best
thing that they could do is try to
change my positioning on the mount in a
way that you know pushed me to a very
low amount you know try to just to to to
to change the way I'm dominating you not
to be you know to get me off the high
mount pretty much are you always is it a
slow is it a fast thing to go from low
to low a high mode slow very slow
because I need to beat your arms because
you're holding me down and the arms need
to come out it's a slope it's a slow
process okay and you just is there like
a yeah okay is is my legs against your
arms yeah so it's my legs pushing your
arms but how do you get them how do you
get your legs into the elbows as long as
this
you know it has to come under the tip of
your elbow because now the legs will
start forcing your arms up
so your legs are like spread out there
no they're in your elbow cannot get
inside my leg right because because that
means I'm in a very low amount
and then I cannot attack because I
cannot ignore that because the mode that
I attack that will
you will start pushing my leg to push me
out
what's the secret to getting the second
hand in
there's two ways either you go four
fingers inside which is the hardest
because with the moment that your two
hands are defending
you'll be blocking the the you know the
the way and I cannot clear and attack
two hands against one so I go summon I
go behind the ear yep so my my grip goes
because for you to defend you need to
get there yeah and when you get there
you elevate your air will expose the arm
lock
put the thumb in and then there's the uh
dreaded
like the other person just waits for you
to Loop the arm over how about that this
will it's a once you get the thumb and
it's over
okay no but when I'm there it's if I get
that it could be a bridging you know
they're trying I mean I'm not using
their hand to post
now your head is your head is very close
to the floor when you've tried to Bridge
and you know my forehead would touch the
floor that would be used as a hand but
it's not on the floor not necessarily
okay because if it's on the floor my
body's collapse over you yeah so there's
no place for my hand for me to work on
your neck so I need some space between
us so I don't completely make it bob up
and down I try to keep a gap between us